[Aplausos]
con la danza de la Victoria vol
latinobus celebró El Triunfo como nuevo
presidente de Nigeria el candidato del
partido gobernante congreso de todos los
progresistas y antiguo gobernador de
lagos obtuvo 8,79 millones de votos por
encima de los 6,98 millones del
principal rival de la oposición a Tico a
bubacar y los 6,1 millones de votos de
Peter Ovi la opción más popular entre
los jóvenes y quien se había consagrado
como el candidato sorpresa que tenía la
esperanza de superar las opciones
tradicionales en su discurso de Victoria
tiene un llamado a la unidad
Este es un momento brillante en la vida
de cualquier hombre y de corazón les
digo Muchas gracias También aprovecho
esta oportunidad para invitar a mis
compañeros competidores para que nos
dejen formar equipo juntos es la única
nación que tenemos es un país que
debemos construir juntos ganamos juntos
para unir piezas rotas debemos trabajar
por la unidad la felicidad y la armonía
la oposición rechazó los resultados y
señaló el nuevo método tecnológico de
recolección de datos como el culpable de
un proceso lleno de dificultades
técnicas la entidad electoral había
prometido subir los resultados de cada
unidad de votación en su sitio web en
tiempo real pero la mayoría de unidades
no pudo hacerlo lo que dificultó la
confianza en el proceso varios políticos
y ciudadanos pidieron la renuncia del
presidente de la comisión electoral
nacional independiente y la anulación
del resultado
los nigerianos tuvieron que esperar casi
cuatro días para obtener resultados
desde el sábado algunos ciudadanos
decidieron custodiar sus votos y en
varias regiones del país grupos de
personas en su mayoría jóvenes se
quedaron hasta altas horas de la noche
iluminando con sus teléfonos celulares
el proceso de conteo con antecedentes de
fraude y violencia durante las jornadas
electorales